في هذا الحي من الطبقة الوسطى في اسطنبول ،
يقول الناس إنهم يزدادون
فقرًا يومًا بعد يوم مع ارتفاع معدل التضخم إلى أكثر
من 20 في المائة ، كما أن الليرة التركية في
السقوط الحر للأتراك تراقب
مداخيلهم تتضاءل مع ارتفاع الأسعار الذي
يرفض دار يقول إنه بالكاد يعيش
على معاشه التقاعدي.  الآن لا يمكنك تحمل تكاليف
إخراج أحفاده ،
لا يمكنك حتى شراء لعبة ، لعبة
تبلغ قيمتها 10 ليرات الآن 40 ليرات.
تحمل تكلفة الأساسيات ،
لم يعد Osuman osel يجلب عربة التسوق
إلى السوق ، لقد
اشتريت حبتين من الباذنجان مع القليل من الكوسة
وقرنبيط واحد أخبرتنا أنه
في الماضي كنت أشتري كيلوغرامات من
كل شيء استخدمته لملء عربة التسوق الخاصة بي
الآن أصبح مستحيل
تقاطع هذه المرأة لتخبرنا أن
كل شيء مكلف للغاية
، وتقول إن زوجها الذي يعمل خياطًا لم
يعمل منذ أكثر من عام بعد أن أصيب
بمرض الجوع ، ويعيش الزوجان على
معاشهما التقاعدي وهو بالكاد يكفي  o تغطية
نفقاتهم ،
أحصل على خبز مخفض من
البلدية ،
لا يمكننا تناول اللحوم الحمراء ولا حتى مرة واحدة في
الأسبوع
، ليس لدي أي فكرة عن كيفية
عيشنا ،
إنه سؤال يدور في أذهان العديد من
الأتراك الذين يراقبون التكلفة في بعض الأحيان
من كل شيء تقريبًا يرتفع
يوميًا ،
فإن الخبز التركي كما هو معروف هو
طعام شائع غير مكلف
ووجبة إفطار أساسية في هذا البلد ،
وقد ارتفع هذا بنسبة 30 في المائة في
الأيام القليلة الماضية ، وهو أمر صادم لكثير من الناس
هنا الذين يقولون
إذا  القمة لم
تسلم مما يلي: فقدت الليرة التركية ما يقرب من نصف
قيمتها هذا العام ، أكثر من 30 في المائة من قيمتها
في نوفمبر وحده ، يلقي معظم الخبراء
باللوم في ذلك على
السياسات الاقتصادية غير التقليدية للرئيس التركي لمحاربة
التضخم ، حيث ترفع معظم الدول
أسعار الفائدة ولكن تركيا تقوم بذلك.  فعل الرئيس الآخر
أردوغان هو معارض قوي
لأسعار الفائدة المرتفعة التي
يصفها بالشر الذي يجعل الأغنياء أكثر ثراءً
والفقير الأكثر فقراً ، وقد دفع البنك المركزي
إلى خفض أسعار الفائدة.  انخفاض
أسعار الفائدة وانخفاض قيمة
العملة كما يقول ستعزز
وظائف الإنتاج والسياحة والصادرات ، لكن الخبراء
يشككون في أن خطة الرئيس
ترفع تركيا الآن
الأسعار للاقتصاد بأكمله
لصالح ما يقرب من 20-25 في المائة من
الاقتصاد.  عدم مساعدة الأسرة حقًا
أه الذي يحاول مواجهة
التضخم المرتفع ، المشكلة أنه لا يوجد
تركيز على محاربة
التضخم الذي هو جوهر
المشكلة الآن في تركيا وعدم القدرة على
التنبؤ التي تأتي مع
النتائج الواعدة التي حققها الرئيس أردوغان في
غضون ستة  أشهر ولكن مع
اقتراب انتخابات عام 2023 سريعًا من الكثير من الركوب على
قدرته على تقديم أداء في محكمة
الرئيس ، كان نجاح أردوغان على مدار
نصف العقدين الماضيين
هو قدرته على تقديم الخدمات
للأسر ذات الدخل المتوسط والمنخفض ، وا
آن يبدو أنه حقق نجاحًا كا
لاً  استدر حيث تعلم أن
الأسر ذات الدخل المتوسط والمنخفض تع
ني بالفعل من هذ
المعاناة  قد يكلف أردوغان في
صناديق الاقتراع ، لكن في الوقت الحالي ، يتحمل الأتراك العاديون
وطأة هذه
المقامرة السياسية جاماني كاراتشاي سي إن إن
اسطنبول